you
hi everyone welcome to the mice
informatics conference thank you for
being here on a special day a Monday
instead of thursday also special place
rather than our normal in the basement
of the BIC today we have an intern
presentation by harsha a buoy and also
myself I will be talking about the wider
picture of what Harsha has been working
on this summer we have had interns here
in D mice for several summers and this
is the last one on this particular grant
but on the training grant but Harsha has
been working with me over the summer
Harsha comes he has spent some time at
Georgia Tech and is currently at
Swarthmore College but will also spend a
little bit of time at MIT so he's
getting around in his undergraduate
experience but he's no stranger to the
Portland area he was raised here and and
so it's been a it's been a good time
working with Harsha over the summer and
I'm going to invite him up to present on
towards automating clinical text
processing for EHR search resources so
let's welcome our show Thank You Stephen
and thank you all for coming I really
appreciate it as soon as that my name is
Harsha and today i'll be presenting my
work towards automating clinical text
processing for EHR search resources so
i'll begin by giving motivation
background for our research timeout
information retrieval as a whole then
we'll proceed into the work i did i've
kind of divvy that up into two parts one
about NLP text processing other
statistical analysis so we'll go through
those and then i'll conclude by giving
away given a time about my takeaways and
conclusions from the research
so our research as a whole is within the
sphere of information retrieval
information retrieval or IR boils down
to the idea of retrieving relevant
information among a large collection
based on a user's need so the most
obvious is obvious example might be like
a web search Google with searching
within your email for certain emails
searching within your laptop these are
all examples of information retrieval
and how we use it on a daily basis so it
boils down to given a user's task the
user will need to extract certain
information from a collection so you
will run a search against that
collection and try and get that
information today users not only expect
that we are able to retrieve the
information but also get that
information ranked in terms of relevance
ranked I are so matching the relevance
as to how closely the information
matches the search query so a main
cornerstone of information retrieval is
being able to evaluate the effectiveness
of search so this is a truly critical
question how efficient and accurate can
we make an IR system ideally and ir
system should be able to retrieve as
many relevant documents as possible and
as few non relevant documents as
possible these can be contradictory
tasks so we need to be able to evaluate
the effectiveness of our search oh sorry
about that that's jumped ahead
and so one way of evaluating the
effectiveness is search is the Crypt is
taking what we call the cranfield
approach the cranfield approach suggests
the idea that first we choose the ways
in which we want to retrieve information
we use those methods and generate ranked
lists and then we evaluate those ranked
lists for effectiveness and so that's
approach that we undertook in this
research and I'll talk a little bit more
about lastly I'd like to touch upon the
idea of natural language processing and
how that can help us with an information
retrieval so we have our large data set
or text that we want to search against
often if we use natural language
processing and process that text and
annotate it with tokens or parts of
speech tags that can help us because
we're breaking down the text run that
search so such as the benefit of using
natural language processing in an IR
system so the combination of electronic
health records and information retrieval
really maximizes utility of both
electronic health records represent an
enormous opportunity for information
retrieval because of the enormity of the
collections and our collection we have
over a hundred thousand documents but
that also represents a challenge how
effectively how efficiently can we
extract information from that massive
collection is there any way we can limit
the amount of data we're looking at just
look at a subset of that data well how
do we search it quickly and efficiently
so these are the questions that we will
delve a little bit deeper into in this
talk so now proceed to the first part of
the research which looked at natural
language processing large-scale
processing of clinical text and our goal
here is to be able to do large
NLP processing for search purposes again
making it easier to break down the text
and do our search so the software that I
use to do this is C takes clinical
pipeline and it's developed by the Mayo
Clinic and it was it's especially useful
for retrieving information from medical
texts so C takes has three main
components it has a collection reader an
analysis engine and a cast consumer cast
being an object and the way it works is
we start with our data and we run a
collection reader against that data the
collection reader interfaces to the data
and it returns a cast object and that
object contains both the documents were
looking at as well as additional
metadata so things we're trying to tag
or extract from the documents and then
we run that cast object through a
collect and analysis engine which
returns an enriched cast object and
finally we use the cast consumer aspect
to output the application specific data
structure that we need in order to read
the process to text so in our case that
was xmi output so what I would do is I'd
work with the collection processing
processing engine from you emo Apache
class I would develop different
collection readers to interface to the
types of text and data that we were
working with and then we'd run with an
analysis engine with it and then we'd
select a cast consumer to write our
output to an XM I document so this would
contain the annotated text and the
information and then we would analyze
those xmi and see our output so that was
the first part that's an overview of the
NLP pipeline
and the large-scale text processing that
we did I'll now move on to the
statistical analysis of EHR search
results portion of my research so the
problem setting here is that we have our
large database of patients we were able
and we have information on those
patients we were able to process all our
texts using NLP and so now we want to
run a search against that database in
this case we had 56 different topics
that we searched against our data and
for each of the 56 searches we 56 topics
we ran 48 different searches one from
each of the parameter groups below the
first one representing for example the
retrieval model and so below I have two
examples of different searches we ran so
we generate an enormous amount of rank
lists because each of the 48 searches
for 56 topics generates a ranked list
and so then what we want to do is we
want to be able to do relevance
judgments on those rank lists to get the
relevant information but it is truly
unfeasible to do those because of the
enormity of the enormous amount of rank
list that we're generating it is really
unfeasible to unfeasible to do that so
the question we asked is are there
combinations of parameters for the
search that are redundant or are there
those that combined offer an optimal
diversity and relevance of patients that
we can use for analysis so for example
if we have to rank lists these are
randomly generated patient IDs how can
we quantify the similarities and
differences so like if two lists are
very identical then we don't want to
have to run relevance judgments on both
of those lifts that's inefficient so is
there a lot of overlap is there a lot of
difference and how do we quantify that
so we used a map score mean average
precision to approximate similarity
essentially for any given list among our
48 we would go through compare each list
individually against the other lists and
take the average of the similarity
scores so this metric allows us to
measure diversity which is important we
want a diverse pool of a buff patients
to do relevance judgments on but we
still need to consider the relevance
keep in mind these lists are ranked and
i showed you to sample rank lists but in
reality those ranked lists contain a
thousand patients and we cut that off at
a thousand and we want to be able to
take into account relevance the ranking
of each individual patient so the
concept we use to deal with relevance is
this idea of pseudo relevance feedback
where you would consider only the top
end patients in a given list to be
relevant so we consider the top n equals
10 patients and then a hundred and two
hundred and a thousand patients in each
list to be relevant therefore taking
into account the ranking portion of of
constructing a diverse and relevant pool
the other idea that we utilize is this
idea of symmetry when we did the score
calculations we did them both as
symmetric scores and asymmetric scores
symmetric scores meaning for a given
pair a B of lists we would consider a
b-and-b a to be like lists so we would
take the average of those two scores and
then when we did a symmetric score
calculation we would consider a b2b a
distinct pair from be a
so I use Seaborn a Python package
matplotlib and we decided upon graphical
analysis for doing our relevance or for
seeing our similarities so this is a
sample heat map at pseudo relevance
level of N equals 200 meaning we
considered only the top 200 patients in
our ranked lists to be relevant and so
we can see that the retrieval model
which is the four parameter group
corresponds to four by four blocks very
well so from that since we can break
them down into four by four cohesive
blocks we can take away that very little
diversity is introduced with the four
parameter group and if we zoom out then
we can see that for the eight by eight
blocks along the diagonal we get good
aside from the diagonal we get good
diversity so this is a sample n equals
200 pseudo relevance sorry and say we
look at the N equals a thousand pseudo
relevance plot the same trends don't
necessarily hold true this shows us that
the way we determine relevance the
pseudo relevance levels do have an
effect on how our pool of diverse and
optimal patients are extracted so now if
we go back to the N equals 200 pseudo
relevance we can look at the 16 by 16
blocks so we're looking at 16 by 16
pairs and we see that for example the
top left and the bottom right are not
eats equally distinguished easily
distinguished from each other except
along the main diagonal so we know that
there's relatively little diversity
introduced by subsetting that data and
we can make additional conclusions like
these
so here if we look at a pseudo relevance
level of N equals 200 and look at both
the asymmetric and symmetric score
calculations the same patterns that we
observe for four by four blocks eight by
eight blocks are maintained for these
results and we can also observe that
there isn't a significant difference
between the asymmetric and symmetric
results so we can conclude that how we
calculate the score does not have a
humongous effect on generating a diverse
and relevant pool so we can make some
conclusions such as you know following
which strategies would allow for an
optimal pool which parameters are in
fact redundant and are unnecessary when
we're doing our relevance judgments how
we can create a set of 12 runs that
would provide us with good relevance so
we were able to hear achieve our goal of
being able to see we how we can generate
from our 48 x 56 number of rank lists a
number of Lists that would provide us
with the optimal pool of patients to do
judgments on and so now I'll go over the
overview of the entire project kind of
tying together how everything meets and
provides for an optimal I our system so
in the yellow we start with all our
structured data we try and break down
that data using natural language
processing you know add metadata this
only makes it easier to do our searching
on and so then what we do is we run
elasticsearch this is our searching
mechanism and we run 56 different topics
in our scenario against the elastic
search and we get different rank lists
for that and so ultimately what we want
to be able to do is do relevant
judgments but because we have such an
enormous amount of rank lists and it is
unfeasible to go through all of them we
have to
some sort of sampling algorithm some
sort of sampling method to reduce the
number of frankness that we need to look
at so for that what we did is of course
the graphical analysis and so then if we
utilize that sampling algorithm reduce
the number of patients we have to look
at while still maintaining optimal
diversity and relevance we can then do
relevance judgments and successfully
extract enough information for ir so to
conclude the first part of my work was
using C take software see takes clinical
pipeline to do natural language
processing I worked on developing
collection readers to interface in
different types of data with the goal
that we can do large-scale text
processing and then we can run that
through elasticsearch and break down and
annotate the text do searching more
effectively and then I also did some
statistical analysis to work on a
sampling method so we could reduce the
number of patients and rank lists that
we have to look at in order to do
relevance judgments and so future work
which will start as soon as this
presentation and Stephens is over is
looking at time benchmarking for see
takes a large scale on say XO cloud or
additional resources and doing parallel
processing for running see ticks so I've
grown enormously over the summer
obviously one of the things I most
enjoyed is seeing my week to week
progression I've only picked up computer
science in the last year and it's a you
know light and day difference doing you
know school work versus something in a
more professional setting and working
with Stephen and understanding you know
how software engineering works starting
with a very small goal texting that very
vigorously understanding that things are
going
change along the way and you have to be
adaptable be innovative try different
methodologies so it's been a very
invaluable experience from a technical
perspective as well as a statistical
perspective you know working with Steven
and others to understand how the you
know merger of statistics and computer
science can produce really innovative
output and how to try and tie these two
subjects together has been something
that will stick with me for quite a long
time so I'd like to think three people
very much in particular first one else
are what is Tamara who was kind enough
to come today Tamra has been great
friend for me I've been very open about
you know me reaching out and she's been
a great resource especially for this
presentation and for the research in
general Tamara is always willing to help
me tie together how the technical
aspects tie into the bigger picture and
looking at it from a non CS perspective
and understanding how the research
really applies in the field of
biomedical informatics and I really
appreciate Tamra's kindness and her
willingness to offer me any help I need
or especially her time and always
chatted up I really appreciate that re o
who's not here Ariel is just he's such a
quick thinker and he has really showed
me how to approach computer science he's
pushed me taught me to be innovative
he's always encouraging me to you know
learn more about bash or Python pushing
me to try out different sub projects as
I work on this and I really appreciate
that and his willingness to share
resources with me and pushed me to
become a stronger computer scientist and
from the technical perspective and last
but not least Steven who's I first want
to thank Steven for providing me with a
very unique opportunity to work with him
this summer Steven is always accessible
he's always willing to talk to you
um always willing to he exhibits endless
patience especially with with me and
he's never willing to he's never not
willing to go through something on the
whiteboard and ensure that you get it he
oh he's good at both pushing you and
making sure you don't stray off course
and continue making progress um you know
I I've gleaned a lot from watching you
do your research and you know how you
approach your research how you approach
being a scientist and how to be
professional and I really appreciate you
taking your time to mentor me this
summer I really do so thank you all for
coming and if you have any questions let
me know yeah
yeah so about parallel life as it was uh
you know it depends on both the types of
documents we were running as well as
which analysis engines and Cass
consumers that we chose i would say for
the data set that we intend to do
parallel processing with it took
probably 25 minutes to do so it's that's
still very long time and so we're hoping
that working with Condor or software HD
condo and working with exa cloud can
really speed up that process
okay thank you
alright thanks again whoa thanks again
for being here and thanks Harsha for
your presentation I'm just going to give
a little bit more context on the
background of sort of EHR search and in
the grant that the grant research that
hardship has been a part of and before I
do that I just want to kind of recognize
one of those diagrams is actually
created by someone in the room Amy Yates
it said source Stephen woo wasn't me
that that drew the diagram so just
wanted to let you know that anyways so
today I'm talking about developing
resources for patient level information
retrieval and basically what we're
talking about is harshil was talking
about is search in electronic health
records right so why would you want to
do search in electronic health records
or why would you want to study it if
you're a clinician maybe you want to do
individual patient search dr. Yuri's
clan are from the cardiovascular
institute a few months ago put up this
quote from a kc VI faculty there was a
survey question describe what you liked
informatics to look like in kc VI within
three to five years and it's kind of
unbounded whatever you could dream of
from informatics and the answer was be
able to identify clinic patients you
vaguely remember something about they
still unlimited data like a medication
they were on diagnosis timeframe you saw
them like a Google search this is
actually not possible in epic right now
it's not possible in many many many of
the HR systems that are deployed around
the US and in other places right now and
you'd think maybe people would have
tackled this before but we'll get to
some of the challenges in a little bit
now you might not be a physician but you
might still be interested in looking for
patients in electronic health records
because you could be a researcher trying
to look for cohorts of patients so
patient cohort search you could be
looking for an
a profile like this when adults under
age 65 with rheumatoid arthritis with a
cyclic sexual inated peptide antibodies
greater than 40 I don't know what that
means but in this kind of query you are
doing sort of a metadata filter on the
age you're also looking at this
diagnosis and saying well are their
symptoms where am I going to find this
thing is it a code or is it in text are
they're synonyms of that and also you're
looking at I think a lab name and n
value I could be wrong maybe it's not it
is okay Tamara says it isn't she's a
medical expert so so looking for
something like this is a known task the
trek medical records track in 2011-2012
did actually try to do this kind look
for this kind of thing so what you're
trying to do is you have evidence in
medical records so for each patient or
for a visit or something like that you
have multiple documents and within those
documents you're looking for pieces of
information that are relevant to your to
your cohort of interest and then you
have to decide for that patient or for
that encounter or something like that
are they in that cohort were out right
it's just a binary decision of whether
they're in or out now like I said this
is actually a challenging setting why
because one there's a lot of data
diversity and you have to do a patient
level aggregation I mean you've got
metadata like demographics as well as
clinical notes and it's not immediately
clear how you harmonize those sources of
information but you need to do it in
order to make a patient level decision
about whether they're in or out
additionally from a linguistics
perspective we would say that there's a
constrained pragmatics right there's a
doctor in a patient they talk to each
other about something that happened in
the past and then they're doing
something in the present and from that
you get clinical notes that are
so it's a constrained setting that
they're writing it in one other thing
that comes out of that constraint
setting is that there's missing data
right it's not like you're constantly
monitoring the patient you just evaluate
them at a particular point in time and
you talk about what's happened at that
one point in time perhaps most
importantly for how this is challenging
for us is that you can't share the data
because unless it's de-identified
because of patient confidentiality
concerns right so Google can access all
of the public websites in the world they
crawl it all that kind of stuff you
cannot crawl EHRs so another reason this
is challenging is because anytime
somebody wants to evaluate something in
search they're really asking does this
work on my problem at my institution and
what we found is that each problem each
institution actually has different
characteristics and performance is very
difficult to characterize across all of
these different settings so so a patient
level ir is challenging the way that one
of the things that we are trying to do
to address this is to build intra
institutional cranfield collections so
harsh i mentioned cranfield collections
and basically they have three components
documents topics documents is what
you're looking in topics is what you're
looking for and relevance judgments is
like harshest said how you know you're
doing a good job or a bad job at finding
the things that you're interested in
right so what I'm going to do for the
rest of the talk is give nine principles
for clinical ir and in fact for clinical
I our resources or collections or
corpora however you want to say it nine
principles and we'll go through those
three aspects of cranfield collections
okay so we'll start with collections the
first thing about
I our collections in the clinical domain
is that we advocate that they should be
stay intra institutional okay so patient
confidentiality is something that's kind
of constrained within an institution
we're never going to have data freely
available everywhere because of HIPAA
because of I arbys because of patient
confidentiality concerns that are you
know rightly those barriers are rightly
there in place so instead of worrying
about patient confidentiality and trying
to get this to researchers everywhere so
they can improve their IR systems and
stuff like that we're going to worry
about that sharing step later and go
ahead and start building collections
within an institution now and what this
means is that you don't have to
de-identify your data in order to share
it with somebody else right and you
don't have to like before you start
building your collection before you
start doing your our hair research okay
we got a de-identified the data and then
we can share it and then we can do all
this stuff on it no we just start on it
now and then worry about the D
identification later and I'll talk about
future work of stuff like evaluation as
a service where hopefully we'll be able
to do intra insta you know do some
things that are like sharing or at least
allowing other researchers to take part
so this project in terms of staying into
institutional we cut we have two sites
ohsu and mayo clinic and we have intro
institutional data within each of those
sites we share things like topics or the
cohort queries that the cohorts that
you're interested in finding we share
systems for for finding patients and we
share results on an aggregate
statistical level but each individual
site has its own data so you use your
own patients your own medical records
and their own relevance judgments so
they make their own assessment for did
this system get what we wanted from our
data set
so one thing one thing to point out here
40 hsu data is that this is actually a
repository IRB so if anybody is
interested in actually using our data
set which you'll hear a little bit more
about as this talk goes on you can
actually write our data set into your
IRB and be able to see it and use the
interface for basically for chart review
that that we've developed so we have it
intra institutionally and it's actually
a resource a repository for others here
at ohsu to be able to use but you do
need to if you're asking a new research
question with the data then you need to
write it into your own RRP okay the
second principle for collections is that
collections are patient populations
right so think about that if you've got
a collection of patients in their data
then whoever's in that pool is your
population of people and if you are
doing a query for a disease in that
population you're basically doing a poor
man's disease prevalence right you're
looking you know is this person in or
out and you're basically looking for
prevalence of that particular cohort
definition or if that cohort definition
is a disease then that's what you're
finding and so so you have you know all
of your patients as your population and
then a subset of them maybe have
rheumatoid arthritis and fit fit the
criteria right now what's also
interesting about this kind of setting
is that when we start looking at
multi-site you have a site to that's
mayo clinic for us and you subset which
one which of these patients have
rheumatoid arthritis well then basically
you can do a poor man's comparative
epidemiology you can look at the two
sites and see how their prevalence
differs ok so our data here at ohsu our
patient population is primary care
patient
from two thousand nine to twenty
thirteen and we have all of their epic
records all is a funny word but pretty
comprehensive both text data and
relevance of structured data pieces from
the electronic health record ok so the
third point here the third principle is
that we want to capture and represent
many data types okay so we do have text
data that's kind of what the typical
search algorithms are using but we also
have structured data in the electronic
health records like I said metadata and
labs and stuff like that and you can use
that to do things like filtering just
like you would do an ad database but
here we'd like to harmonize that with a
sort of text search system as well
another thing that you could use
structured data for is discourse context
for text so that the maybe you know some
of the demographics have tell you
something about what to expect in the
text or what something means in the text
because you know what kind of patient
you're dealing with something like that
so you can see here in our data we have
this demographics field shows that we
have about a hundred thousand patients
in our in our data set and that's one
kind of structured data and this notes
field is the main field whether you have
clinical text and we have about a 10
million notes there and so we have about
a hundred notes per patient on average
in this in the data set here at ohsu so
there's a lot of data types it ranges
from 30 to around thirty two million
current medications down to 32,000 about
32,000 surgeries overall so it can range
depending on what kind of data type how
many are there in the system or in there
in the database
ok so we've looked at the collection the
next thing for cranfield collections is
topics in other words what are you going
to be looking for from your collection
and so principle number four is to get
topics from diverse and practical
sources so you could be looking for so
there's a difference between primary and
secondary uses of EHR data primary is
kind of like that first setting where a
doctor might be interested in using
search for clinical care right they're
using the HR for clinical care where as
a secondary use of electronic health
record is you know it's already been
collected for care how can we look back
on that or or look at that and use it
for some other purpose other than what
it was or you know then patient care
itself so we're most mostly focusing on
the ladder on the secondary use of EHR
data but partly what this means is that
we don't have query logs or active
systems we don't actually have searched
implemented somewhere so Google will go
and whatever you enter into that box it
owns and it knows what everybody else
has been searching in that box and what
you've been searching in the buff that
box we don't have a box like that right
now so we don't have a query log where
we can see oh this is what people are
interested in it and how they phrase it
in in Xyz right so we don't have active
systems to learn from so we developed a
set of a limited set of secondary use
topics that we could use as a regression
set that we could test many systems
against but we try to make it diverse
from practical sources so we have some
that are public health or clinical
investigations some of these topics so
we have requests to ohsu matt oak tree
and we also have some from mayo
Nick and the Rochester epidemiology
project which is a public health project
at Mayo Clinic so with these with these
sets we have sort of Health clinical
investigation kind of use cases so
that's one kind of practical use but we
also have some informatics research use
cases like phenotype knowledge base had
some cohorts defined and so we adopted
some of those we also adopted some from
the National Quality forum which is like
an operations improvement also some
informatik good informatics research
from that kind of thing so these are all
practical questions you might ask
practical cohorts you might be looking
for in electronic health records but for
various reasons so diverse impractical
okay so that's number four number five
kind of arising from that we have
because we have both specific and vague
sources a diversity of sources we need
to actually use multiple representations
of each topic in order to capture the
tune or capture and normalize the
different kinds of stipulated topics
that are there so you can see a really
short summary statement a here on the
Left be there is a brief summary and
mock clinical case and see kind of a
summary plus some structured data right
so there's inclusion exclusion stuff
there so that's for the topics basically
the theme of diversity finally for the
relevance judgments what does it take to
get stuff you know human judgments that
are going to tell us whether our systems
search systems are doing well or not our
relevance judgments our first
observation is that we need to use
medical experts as relevance judges and
this is basically providing a human
rating of topic patient relevant
so is this topic sorry is this patient
that I'm looking at and reviewing their
chart for relevant to the cohort that
I'm interested and we can't do
crowdsourcing on this one because of
patient confidentiality you can't just
get anyone on Mechanical Turk to look at
somebody's identified health records
another reason is because of medical
expertise you have a topic like this one
adults with postherpetic neuralgia using
cute enza something like that I don't
know what that is Turk or probably
doesn't know what that is and so you
need some medical expertise in order to
do some of this judging so we have
expert annotators both here Tamara
Timmons is in the room and at Mayo
Clinic Donna okey so number seven number
seven of nine treat relevance assessment
as chart review and this basically falls
out from the previous one chart review
is a known quantity in the medical
domain and it's reasonably more
complicated than doing web pages right
if you're judging whether a web page is
relevant to a query your you look at one
webpage and you say okay that's relevant
or not if you're doing visits or
encounters in our data set like each
time a patient comes in for hospital
stay 5.9 documents for judgment if
you're looking at a whole patient and
all their information over a hundred
documents / judgment right so this is
pretty complicated of a setting
fortunately the time it takes to judge
this many documents doesn't scale with
the number of documents but it's still a
more complicated task and it's
compounded by the fact that you have
compound complicated criteria right so
we have topics like this one and within
this topic there's under age 65
rheumatoid arthritis positive cyclic
sister Linda peptide antibodies not on a
genetic opt-out list and an encounter
date within the last two years that's
five things
that somebody who's reviewing a chart
has to keep in mind in order to say
whether they're in or out of this
particular topic right and so basically
there's a it's a difficult task there's
a cognitive load that's hard for people
to keep in mind so hey maybe we need to
find ways to make intermediate judgments
or sub judgments about things so we
designed the patient relevant assessment
interface pra I also worked on by people
in this room so this is what it looks
like and this is also our eighth
principle basically simplify the task
with a good UI and the effort it takes
to put put in put into design this we
think has helps the more repeated
process of lots of judgments and so what
you see here is the ability for each
line for each patient each patient is a
line for each patient to say whether
they fit or don't fit into that cohort
you see on this screen the possibility
to say on this document or this piece of
metadata or this piece of this lab test
or something you can say yes or no and
that supports or doesn't support them
being into it into the cohort so
basically we have the ability to do this
exact kind of sub judgments intermediate
things that were mentioned before okay
so how do we actually show figure out
what patients to show in this framework
this is kind of where what harsha worked
on in the second part of his talk came
in how do we generate the pools to show
in pra I we had 100,000 patients we
generated baseline runs and did sampling
just like harsh i mentioned and we
actually ran this with a sampling where
we put out 45 possible patients from
from out of their lists and then did a
set union of sampled patients to for
each of those 48 runs
so combine that and those are the
patients to be judged Harsha is
basically helping us figure out are
there ways to figure to improve sampling
methods are there ways to say which of
these two kind of actively learn and
figure out which of these patients and
which of these runs that generated the
patient list should be used okay number
nine it's kind of the last one we have
we have already this process with
collections topics and judgments go back
through all of it and kind of measure
the feasibility of your project of your
process so Tamra took five topics and
looked at you know how well is the
interface performing how well are the
runs produced relevant and how long does
it take to assess these things and what
you see with the assessment time here on
the right is that there's kind of a
variability in assessment time you've
got four point two minutes per patient
on the last topic whereas there's only
one minute per patient on the third
topic so there's a variability and how
long it takes to say whether a patient
fits into your cohort or not so with
this kind of like preliminary judgment
what that enables you to do is iterate
if necessary and you can improve and
improve your process and one of the
things that we did from this is we
actually introduced the topic
representation see with more structured
topics because of because of this kind
of measuring the feasibility of the
project the process okay so basically
what I've talked about today is our
collections that are interests
institutional they represent patient
populations and they link multiple data
types okay all right we have I our
topics
that are from a diversity of sources and
are represented in a diversity of ways
and then we have our relevance judgments
that are basically considered chart
reviews by medical experts and we do
them with this PR AI interface so our
future work is going to be on multi-site
evaluation as a service basically
creating this huge collection where only
ohs year researchers can use it it seems
like it might be wasted effort but it's
definitely not wasted if we figure out
evaluation as a service where instead of
sending data to people to two algorithms
so that they can evaluate themselves and
send us their results we have them send
their algorithms to us and and then run
those results within our firewall and
all that kind of stuff and figure out
their results and send it back to them
so it's a different paradigm and that's
kind of where we're going next with this
so thank you so like to open up to
questions either to me or are sure if
your closet if you have a late-breaking
question how do you envision people
sending their
question okay i just asked how do you
envision for sending their albums
because that paper yeah the question was
how do we envision having a burning
sense of us and I'll give a simple one
word answer for now ducker anybody else
other questions I can elaborate on that
if you want but we're still writing the
grant so
there was
all right looks like we're done early
thank you all for coming to the message
my ex comments
you
you